imagine yourself standing before a 100
foot wave of ocean water
for most I'm guessing running to safety
would be the first instinct that would
kick in
but for today's guest the immediate
thought is singular
grab your board and let's go surfing
fear is something that we choose
something we manufacture in our mind we
fully embrace the moments fear does not
exist
his name is Garrett McNamara and he is
an internationally recognized big wave
surfer who commanded Global attention by
surfing one of the world's largest waves
I just want to sorry if the goal is to
keep surfing and has accomplished a
myriad of other just absolutely insane
surfing Feats like surfing waves
generated by a 300 foot Glacier in
Alaska giant barrels breaking on shallow
Jagged reefs Garrett and his team are
also the subjects of the hit HBO
docu-series you might have seen called
100 foot wave which thrillingly
Chronicles their pursuit of the largest
waves in the world there's nothing that
we can't do if we want if we put our
mind to it in today's conversation we
discussed Garrett's background how he
began surfing we talk about the 100 foot
wave Quest and the docu-series that
captured it all and as an added bonus
Garrett's wife Nicole absolutely his
partner in all things joins the
conversation at the end to Enlighten us
on the manifestation spiritual practice
she and Garrett utilize to guide their
decision making and execute on their
audacious goals I absolutely love this
conversation Garrett is just he's a one
of a kind quite a character as you'll
soon find out and the exchange with him
and Nicole is just one I won't soon
forget and with that I give you the one
the only Garrett McNamara
[Music]
super nice to meet you I'm really glad
we could make this happen I kind of feel
like I know you though because I've been
consuming so much of your uh content
your adventures your experiences of
course the docu-series which is
unbelievable and I I presume that you're
in Los Angeles because the Emmys is that
the main reason that was the main reason
yeah you guys took the W too oh yeah I
couldn't believe it it's uh
more than we expected from this whole
mission right Journey that's got to be
pretty surreal I mean the Arc of
everything that you've endured over many
years to arrive at this place where
you're on the receiving end of like so
much recognition you know it's got to be
you know at times a little bit uh
destabilizing or sort of you know
strange
yeah it's really um I feel like to pinch
me something like is this really
happening and but then when we're in
Portugal and nazaree and you're walking
up the cliff and there's thousands of
people and they're all thank you and
then you start crying with all these
cheers of joy and um just gratitude yeah
I mean I think that's really at the
heart of what almost interests me the
most about your story you know it
reminds me of
um
a conversation I had with Alex Honnold
after he had free soloed lcap but like a
year before the movie came out
and through that conversation I felt
like I understood what he had
accomplished similarly with yourself
like I'd seen all the video clips and I
kind of thought I had a sense of what
you were up to out there in Portugal but
it wasn't until I saw free solo and I
watched the docu-series that I had a
heavy dose of like oh you actually
didn't really understand at all like
there's so much more that went into this
adventure than than meets the eye and
it's only through like telling the story
in real time with all this archival
footage that you guys had that you can
truly appreciate what has been
accomplished here and a big piece at the
center of it is this community that you
built that you you know took years to
construct prior to even you know
dropping in on the huge wave that kind
of made headlines around the world
yeah for us it it was 100 but the team
that we could not have done anything
that we did without this amazing team
and in the beginning we were all
marching to the same beat with the same
goals and desires and
and it just was so effortless and so it
just every day was just so fun and
enjoyable and everybody was just
happy all day every day yeah well I mean
there was definitely some challenges
here and there there was a lot I mean
what I took from it was that you really
invested like you're like the only way
this is ever going to work is if I build
a team and a network and generate
community and consensus around this
massive goal that I have and that's by
you know basically working with everyone
in the community there to you know
create a situation for Success
um you know without understanding that
and watching the document documentary
like I would have thought oh you just
dropped you arrived there you brought
your Towing guy you got the Waverunner
and you just shoot out and you just
check it out you know it wasn't that at
all
and this is a different animal due to
the fact that it was just a big beach
break a big closeout beach break that uh
was deemed impossible like of a number
of people she went there before we went
there and and had everything we're ready
and said it no it's impossible you can't
get back out what you might be able to
ride a wave that jet ski comes in it
won't be able to go back out right and I
was just I had a dumb luck or I don't
know I don't think it was dumb luck at
all like I think it was an engineering
problem that you took a lot of time to
try to solve and figure it out like a
workaround to to make it work but maybe
we should I want to get into your
backstory because it's so you know
insane but let's talk about nazare right
now like for somebody who hasn't seen
the docu-series and maybe only knows you
as a guy who surfs big waves like let's
start at you know the beginning when you
uh you receive this email and this
invitation to go to Portugal
uh it became um in like
2005 or seven somewhere around there and
and he just he emailed me saying um he's
like a city commerce he was a
bodyboarder and he worked for the uh
just uh in the mayor's office and a
branch of that called Nazareth qualifica
and he was
um and hit up Sports programs and but as
a child he had been on that Lighthouse
dreaming somebody surfing the big waves
and then that dream just until he was in
a position to hunt
to find somebody he actually sent an
email to Laird Hamilton first didn't get
a reply then he sent one to Carlos
Burley didn't get a reply I was third
that was the third choice on the list
reply but it was a number of years after
that email before you took the first
trip out there to scout it out well my
wife doesn't like to take credit for
this but I give her all the credit
because that email was sitting there in
my inbox
up from a while back when we met and she
was going through all my emails getting
me organized and then she came across
that email and she's like but this and
I'm like oh some some guys want me to go
to Portugal and see if their waves any
good and any big the Amo said if can you
come and test our wave and see if it's
good and see if it's big and if it's
good and big can you help promote our
town right and uh little tiny fishing
Village one month after she saw the
email
you were there there yeah so other
Surfers had it wasn't it wasn't like a
total secret that there was a big wave
there it's just nobody had ever had the
odd audacity to try it or how come like
it took so long for people to notice
what was happening there it was deemed
impossible and a Jose Gregorio who's
Quicksilver Portugal awesome good Surfer
decent pilot he tried he the guy sent me
pictures of all their jet skis with just
blowing apart yard sale and so they
never went back and then when I got
there tow surfing was now frowned upon
you know there was the media and a group
of surfers and I don't know if they
actually really planned it but really
felt like it to just kill toe surfing
and uh so torso from was dead it was
crowned upon unless maybe you're at
Australia at a slab or chopo when it
gets too big and you can't paddle but
even then it was like
yeah so early this is like 2008 2009
yeah and you get there in 2010. and it
was uh to be very honest there would
still be nobody there today if we didn't
actually
give it a try right because nobody was
going to try and toe serving wasn't cool
once kailani got into the started
promoting posting his toe surfing yeah
then it was cool again thank you Kai
yeah I mean I mean
right yeah yeah yeah we'll get into that
inflection point of view you know
watching him do that for the very first
time but you ought to flyer you know you
and Nicole head out uh to nazaree and
that first season out there was really
mostly just Recon like trying to
understand what was happening watching
the waves meeting with people at the in
the government and you know trying to
build a team and make sense of how you
could do this you know quote unquote
safely or as safely as possible yeah we
call that the exploration here where
we're just exploring and
figuring out all the challenges that we
might face figure out Solutions and um
we were so like it was it never received
that type of
welcome anywhere in the world where the
Portuguese Navy opens their door and
opens all the charts and and I mean
everybody and anybody was at our you
know ready to help with whatever they
need whatever information they had we
didn't have a lot of funding I mean
there was a little restaurant Celeste
restaurant she gave us meals for seven
dollars was her contribution yeah uh
Luis obedo was a fish company his he's
the biggest fish company in Nazareth
they gave ten thousand dollars but other
than that we had nothing
and um Lino from nasbury water fund he
came in personally and just asked what
we needed and whatever we needed he made
it happen so yeah and and that requires
uh you know a healthy dose of humility
like you're this Hawaiian Surfer guy you
have this understanding like look I'm
not Portuguese I can't just come in here
and pretend like I know what's going on
I have to make sure that I have the
support of the community before I even
attempt to do something that's going to
put this town in the spotlight
was that part of the thinking or was it
just this is your natural tendency like
a kind of natural tendency I assembled
we have I don't like to call it um my
families around the world like where
we've assembled assembled in Tahiti and
Chile in Peru you know all over the
world we have our little family set up
during my toe surfing career so wherever
I want to do whatever big swell was
going
we would have something already in place
so we call we're coming and boom
everything's ready right
um but it was nothing like what happened
in Portugal we got the government you
got the town you got oh actually the
town at first did not want to know us
they were like
they're very passionate you know very
loving and I was the guy that was gonna
die tomorrow so they didn't want to get
to know me because they didn't want to
be sad when I did right they had this
long history of all these fishermen
dying right as a result of this wave and
and what's interesting is what makes
that wave so big so talk a little bit
about like why that wave is so different
and special
it's crazy because 10 miles down the
road at piniche it'll be six feet and in
Nazareth at 60 feet it's uh there's this
underwater canyon that's 25 miles long
two or three times the size of the Grand
Canyon and it kind of bottlenecks so it
starts out really wide and then it gets
really narrow right before the right
before the last Rock and the lighthouse
right it runs perpendicular to the shore
it actually passes the lighthouse
and runs all the way to the beat there
so this the energy keeps moving with all
of its full raw power without getting
disrupted by a a reef or a or a sand
bank or a shelf in that Canyon but on
the right side is this shelf which is um
it gets like 60 feet deep at the deepest
and over here you got a thousand feet
deep where the wave breaks and then um
where the wave breaks on the Shelf it's
like 30 to 40 feet the biggest swells
we've ever had might be breaking into 60
feet deep but these these swells are
going slower or these waves are going
slower as they hit the Shelf in the same
exact waves goes faster down the canyon
and then they they miss each other when
it gets to the where they're going to
break but then they they turn inside to
each other so it creates a wedge right a
crazy wedge and there's this when you
when you watch video kind of zoomed out
a little bit it just looks like a
massive washing machine like we're sort
of used to when we think of big waves we
think of these you know beautiful clean
sets on the North Shore of Oahu where
they're perfect curls and they're coming
in and it's all kind of very you know
pristine and tropical and this just
looks like you know the gods are angry
like it's just crashing you know like
how do you even make sense of like where
to be and where the wave is gonna break
and it looks like there's another wave
coming from the side like making sense
of all of that and trying to understand
like is this even possible to ride seems
like a hefty equation to solve I think
that's what's most uh what we love the
most about it you it's never this same
twice and there's always a challenge
there's all number one picking the wave
like sometimes you have the biggest foe
you ever saw coming at you and you start
driving for it and that cross wave
cancels it and it doesn't even it just
kind of go around and there's nothing
and other times it'll be a medium size
and when it hits the wedge perfect
bigger than like 10 20 feet bigger than
you expected and
um yeah it's it's never the same ways
twice it's always challenging it's it
the the biggest challenge of all is
right in front of the cliffs
or first speak left brakes if you fall
right there there it's the water is so
foamy and so aerated and the hold Downs
are so brutal and right in there is like
a river Rip Tide just coming out full
force so you have this current pulling
out and the wave coming in and if you
fall there it's almost impossible to
come up when you finally do
the next wave is usually right there
there's no time to get you
and if the ski can get in there
you grab the guy and you try to go in
the aerated water you don't move so it's
like somewhere you never want to fall
we've had a few people fall there and
and they've had the worst experience or
the most challenging experience they've
ever had in the water yeah what was what
was interesting was figuring out like
there's the I want to talk about the
mechanics of of of Towing into these
waves but what the Epiphany was really
realizing that you needed an additional
Wave Runner uh for rescuing the person
in case they they wipe out right because
when they're in that foamy No Man's Land
you can't even see where they are and
the guy who dropped you off the towing
guy can't get there right like it's
impossible so the only way to make it
semi-safe is to have two wave Runners
out there one specifically for Rescue
yeah and one of the biggest keys to
success is your eye in the sky your
spotter on the cliff who is
communicating with both
drivers and even the Searchers
well we started out to have her for
safety but then we're saying which way
is she spotting the good waves right so
it is this huge team effort
um I under appreciated the skill level
required for the toe-in Wave Runner
pilot like that's a whole thing and you
know the docu-series does an amazing job
of demonstrating like how trained up
these people have to be and how in sync
like there has to be this you know
connective tissue almost a you know uh a
Synergy and unspoken connection between
you and and uh your toe-in pilot in
order for that to work right and then
you've got Nicole on the cliff and these
other people and you guys all have
walkie-talkies and you're communicating
the whole time you're wearing
specialized uh wetsuits that have
inflation in them so you're not going to
get caught in the washing machine
underwater for too long like so so many
cautions and so many team members in
order to make this thing operate
yeah the the inflation is the best
invention in big wave surfing what's
even better is the flotation that we put
into our suits so as long as we have a
little flotation in a suit whether you
pull or if it malfunctions or if it
breaks you're still going to pop up
sooner or later somewhere and we'll find
you but with the inflation it's just
like yeah you're coming up you look like
a fisherman man or like a Marvel
character in those things big time Big
Time and
um yeah the drivers what you were asking
earlier I mean we have the initial Tower
who usually is the guy who first
responder but then everything's running
perfect you have one guy on the on the
left and one guy on the right watching
the person serve so the driver usually
gets you if he but he can't see usually
because he is hard to get to the
shoulder really fast to be able to look
down so you have the guy in the left and
the Gunner actually eyeballing and you
have the in the sky so who if one of
them misses then the next one comes if
they were going to go left but all of a
sudden last minute went right the guy on
the right guy so yeah there's those are
the definitely the lar Lifeline yeah
those those Safety Drivers yeah yeah
yeah and it's it's cool I mean you're
Irish by descent right yeah and you got
like uh you got
um initially you have Al who's uh
Irishman right Legend and then you got
Katie who's an Englishman like none of
these guys are Polynesian or Portuguese
or anything like that like all northern
European guys like you're like an
unlikely you know set aside the age
piece which we're gonna get into like
you're an unlikely candidate for this
whole world to begin with an unlikely
success story starting from Pittsfield
Massachusetts 100 miles from the ocean
um
yeah the team you know if I could do it
all over I wouldn't change anything but
if I was going to do it the way that
would be set up for success I would have
brought Kelly imamala my Hawaiian driver
uh because he doesn't miss ever and he's
I I don't even come in and see in like
your third or fourth year there right
he's I know he's in season two I'm not
sure if he made season one at all was he
in season I think he's in season one
yeah yeah okay okay that's good because
Katie was back home for her spell right
because he lost his oh yeah for 2012 he
put me on that wave oh and he missed me
which he never does it was like crazy
the Hawaiian Miss so he flew off the ski
yeah right but um I wouldn't change a
thing I mean Cody is the most selfless
uh my favorite person in the world and
then almania is just a gentle giant and
the whole team we were just and it was
easy you know because they had a lot of
um
for lack of order we got a lot of
respect they're like you know kids so
they they actually did whatever I wanted
whenever I wanted so I could really
train them up yeah and really um know
that my desires were gonna be met every
time as long as they were learned and
you know train them up right right they
were going to listen and train up how
I'd like them to be what and you're very
specific in like what you want and what
you need like what is the most important
uh you know sort of skill set or or
capacity of the toe and pilot like what
are you looking for like what do they
need to have and be they have to be very
in tune with the ocean very confident
and very comfortable
and um you know I've I've had some
drivers that I worked with for years and
and they will never get it they're
basically they don't they're not in tune
with the ocean or I don't know what it
is but they'll never get it and other
guys will get it like right out of the
gate um Cody was already good and Al was
already good
the first day when we towed I caught
this long wave and I'm not sure exactly
how I ended up on the inside because he
picks me up and we're flying in and it's
like the first times that we're gonna
try and come back out and
right there I was like it's on you're
good we're ready yeah and when you're
out there and I want to work out but
you're on the back of that sled and you
don't know where you're going but you
can feel it and he was flying in and
then the biggest turn and then I was
like yeah
that reminds me of how Anderson Cooper
describes you you know like Garrett when
he's talking about these wages like
imagine you're it's like you're you're
cruising down the side of a skyscraper
but the skyscraper is collapsing on top
of you like I've never met anyone like
Garrett like it's so animated he is the
best yeah he is the best so let's let's
work our way up to that 70 foot eight
footer like that was that was in the
second year so the first year you're out
there you spend the whole winter and
it's really just getting everything set
and you go back the second year and was
there a sense of
possibility like okay now we're gonna
execute we have all these pieces in
place I have the support I need I've got
the guys who have my back they know what
they're doing like everything is firing
on all cylinders and we're good to go
yeah we I was super confident I I
visualized that we manifest it we knew
it was happening my wife Nicole she's
like
when she wants to manifest something it
happens the next day so we're gonna
we're gonna get into the manifesting
piece
um yeah the funny thing is my whole life
I had been manifesting but I didn't
really know until I uh watched the
secret like I don't know maybe five
years after it came out or something and
I was like oh that's what I've been
doing this whole time yeah it's just
you're uh you're a generator manifester
right in the human design I'm actually
uh
yeah a generator yeah for sure
um of course you are right yeah so uh
even though you had spent that entire
first winter there it wasn't like like
was anybody like in the surf world like
oh Garrett's out there was that that was
sort of dismissed like oh who knows what
he's doing out there actually uh Kelly
and I were communicating before I went
there yeah and he uh
he would go there to hide from everybody
he panishes you know an hour 45 minutes
away where the contest is and he would
go to Nazareth the lighthouse and just
hide and he surfed a couple of little
breaks and had fun and but really just
enjoyed the power and just sat there in
awe and um I we talked about a month
before I was going and then uh before
you were going the first time yeah and
then two weeks before I went he was on
the lighthouse he's like Garrett
it's it's big it's gnarly if one mistake
you might not be going home please be
really careful out here yeah
yeah well you know those are wise words
you know from a guy who knows yeah but
you had other plans right so you go out
the second year
um
and uh this is where everything kind of
lines up right and and I gather that
like the swells are pretty frequent
right you're not waiting you're not
having to wait around too long before
these big waves start rolling in like
it's pretty on the regular yes most
frequent big wave spot in the world just
the wind has to align but nowadays the
guys are going out no matter what it's
like even if it's all windy and choppy
they're out there just charging yeah
yeah so how long into that second season
before you catch this 78 footer
it was November 11th what or November
1st
um
Nicole do you happen to remember when we
actually were I think we it was pretty
quick wasn't it
from the day we landed till the world
record wave
it was the first well we called audience
uh cardi and all over and it was on
right right
so you drop in on this huge wave it gets
documented you already have like this
documentary crew with you though like
how was was that documentary was the
docu-series already locked in and in
place or was this just kind of amateur
footage that got cobbled together later
once the documentary City Hall hired a
still photographer to document what
we're doing
he actually had a couple go or I had
GoPros I had GoPros
um he had a camera that was HTV so you
could actually film
second I landed we became friends and I
said please do not turn the video camera
off right so you just have all this
footage yeah and he did good yeah he did
really good yeah it's incredible how
much archival footage there is from
those first two years
when nobody was expecting anything yeah
so you you ride the 78-footer
it's
a story that quickly goes around the
world essential essentially the the
biggest wave ever served in the history
of surfing my first question is and I
kind of already know the answer but I
think it would be instructive for for
everybody listening or watching is how
do you determine the size of a wave and
I loved CJ's description in in the
docu-series about the kind of uh
less than scientific sciency approach to
calculating all of this it's literally
impossible to actually get the height of
a wave just because of the I mean if you
got the Google Earth things now and you
got these watches and you got everything
measuring everything and it's still
pretty much impossible because you got
to be able to come out to the flat and
everybody's measuring about 20 30 people
feet up from the flat
and then
you got the Contour are you actually
measuring the distance of that Contour
or you're measuring a straight line
straight up it's it's super
controversial super
um the finding the top is very easy
but then in the rules it's where the
surfer is so say it's 80 feet here but
the surface over here and it's 60 feet
and then
the change is a lot sure it it was where
the surfer is on the way under his feet
there instead of the other 30 feet or 40
feet because the surfer's not
necessarily at the bottom of the wave
never we're never actually at the bottom
and the wave could be getting larger as
the ride goes on yeah right and then you
have to take that so you you estimate
where the bottom is you know where the
where it's cresting at the top and then
you have to measure uh the size of the
surfer
and the Surfers generally in some kind
of crouched position they're not
standing straight up so you can't say
six feet or whatever so you have to
estimate that and then you just do
multiples of that to calculate it like
it's there's no way that you can get an
accurate reading on this and this is
something that is completely ephemeral
like it exists for a moment and then
it's gone and there's no way of going
back in time to figure it out and
people's careers are based around it and
they said that they measured my shin
bone to get the size of the 78 foot wave
and I nobody measured my shin bone that
you remember right and then there's the
political aspect of it right like who's
making these decisions and what are
their motivations
usually as sponsors in control but uh
once in a while there's no Rhyme or
Reason you're just like but it maybe
it's some continent they want to sell
more in that country or do more with
surf in that country
um and then other times I think it's
right on the right on the money the
person who wins is supposed to win but
mostly it it's con it's politics but
most is the WSL manages that now right
so they're they're independent on some
level yes yeah yeah that's good they're
they've grown women surfing Beyond I I
love watching women surfing now the
level of the surfing
and at first I was like what are they
they're just trying to grow why but
they'd hats off they crushed it out of
the park and um with this the tour
they're doing great
um with the big waves it's it's always a
battle with the Surfers and the
organization and hopefully someday
everybody will see eye to eye and it'll
go where it should be today from toe
surfing should be like the NASCAR of of
surf I mean it could be huge you get
these teams organized you get these
garages you get
yeah it could be huge and people could
really be um they could be retiring but
right now if one or two actually get
paid and the rest are just yeah they're
hanging on by a thread working working a
day job and so they can surf yeah well I
I you know I feel like that's changing
though you know people like yourself and
Laird and you know figuring out ways of
making people interested in this art
form and sport is really you know
creating a a larger and larger audience
for this I mean every everybody wants to
see somebody surf a gigantic wave right
as you know right so you you surf the
78-foot wave and the video and the
photograph like quickly goes all around
the world and suddenly you being this
you know relatively obscure later in
life Surfer
um
is kind of foisted into the spotlight
and there's a lot of you know commentary
around the validity of this whole thing
right my sense was that the traditional
surfing Community was somewhat
dismissive like oh it's a mushy wave
like that wave doesn't really count like
who knows what's going out in Nazareth
like where you know there was there was
a level of dismissiveness initially yeah
that would definitely yeah the whole
mainly the surfing world the rest of the
world loved it sure well we know what do
we know well you know CNN it pops up on
CNN and you see this tiny spec you like
going down this insane wave that looks
like you know a sea monster right and
you're like wow that's unbelievable but
the main reason it was dismissed number
one they didn't know or understand
um never been there
um number two
it uh toe surfing was dead as I shared
earlier so nobody wanted to know
anything about toe surfing in the
surfing world is that true though
because Mavericks was a thing by now and
you know and they closed the Jets stay
closed no more jet skis yeah they turned
it into a sanctuary it still is today I
mean
um a couple guys go out when it's really
big and our safety guys are allowed but
um yeah they've closed hole surfing
there
um
but it was challenging yeah to you know
I I was calling all my friends I was
emailing everybody I'm gonna come on
over this wave and and then all of a
sudden all this like whatever so my wife
was like once you cross over to CNN
uh be ready because now you're in that
world right uh are you sure you want to
do that and I'm like I just wanted sorry
if the goal is to keep surfing so
whatever uh it's a easiest way to keep
surfing and if we got the attention of
the whole world then and the Surfers
will come they'll they'll get it
together and everybody Embraces it now
and everybody's just so supportive and
we were at Malibu yesterday it was a
dream all the boys and we're taking all
the kids out and just felt like home I
felt it was so special I was I've had a
lot of good days in Malibu I love Malibu
but yesterday was so so special yeah
that's cool that's cool and it is
amazing because now everybody you know
everybody in the world who knows
anything about surfing knows Nazareth
right and there's all this energy and
focus on uh the winter season there and
what's gonna happen and it really goes
back to you you're like you're patient
zero and you created like all all of
that out of your imagination and a
simple email that Drew you there
initially and this belief you know this
idea that something that had not yet
existed was possible
it's cool it's really cool thank you
yeah man so even after that happens you
go back for the third year and it's not
like oh suddenly like hundreds of
surfers are showing up the only people
that show up and I can't remember
whether that was the third or the fourth
winner there was the you know a handful
of these Brazilians yeah
they were the only ones who said we need
to go check this out yeah there was uh
a few teams that showed up on their own
and they were all hungry and they were
yeah it was it was interesting to watch
it was fun to actually see somebody else
ride the wave yeah to go on the cliff
and actually watch for a minute yeah but
what was interesting to me about that
was the fact that they came in and
despite the fact that you had three
seasons banked and all this experience
they didn't seem all that interested in
tapping into that knowledge base they
were going to go and figure it out on
their own terms and they kind of got
spanked I mean Maya almost died and that
was as a result of that and it was a
totally unnecessary
um yeah it was very surprising I'm an
open book I love to share I love
everybody to succeed I don't try and
hide things to you know I go I got the
best board and I'm just gonna not let
anybody have access I share everything
and and I was ready to share everything
but I didn't want to impose you know
when you impose people don't listen
anyway
and my we were talking with Carlos and
Maya and maybe a few other talking about
Maya gabera and then went on to be the
you know
the world record Setter for the serving
the largest wave
for a woman she's super inspiring
herself uh her story and her her
achievements and her movies coming out
soon but um my wife says look where I
was leaving and she she grabbed me so
you got to go back there and tell them
that if they fall here they don't go
that way they go that way so I grabbed
him and I told him okay if anybody Falls
they go to this they go south they don't
go because you would think it would go
north up the beach but you go south into
the corner and uh and I explained very
clearly but then when that accident
happened they did the opposite they went
and they didn't have a rescue Waverunner
that was the big thing right yeah yeah
enough communication I think was down or
something yeah so Maya goes down hard
she basically not only almost died like
did she actually die for a moment like
they had to resuscitate her
um it was bad right and then she has
like a four-year period of trying to
rehabilitate herself before she comes
back yeah she's
superhuman that girl is um
she's excelling as as good or better
than all the guys out there these days
um yeah the uh when she when she finally
broke the record which what was that
2020 I think when she was like a 73
footer or something yeah
um The New York Times article about that
was written by Adam skolnick who's my
co-host here oh no yeah yeah wow yeah
um yeah so we've talked about it guys
she'd be fantastic and she's very well
spoken yeah cool
um talk to me about the relationship
with fear I mean this is the low-hanging
fruit question right everybody wants to
know like what is you know what is it
about you that makes you uniquely suited
to you know approach these giant waves
and you know sort of from a perspective
of enthusiasm rather than Terror
well my trainer says my body type is
perfect for big waves I don't know about
all of it just because why the length of
the legs and the arms and the Torso and
yeah but um
I had surfed the glacier waves in the
last of the waves are caused by cabin
glaciers and
after that day there's fear that I
the fear that I had when that Glacier
gave down on that first wave and I let
go of the rope and around this teeny
little wave and looking at the glacier
thinking oh [__] it could fall again and
then I'm dead crushed it was
overwhelming
um and then when I went back I was
already I'd already served so many waves
so many big waves all over the world and
got in so many good poundings my the way
I always approached it was
All or Nothing get to get the ultimate
ride the ultimate feeling and so I would
always put it go as deep as possible if
I could put it all on the line and with
that approach you don't make 50 of your
waves and I didn't mind because I felt
like ready and I could handle it I could
hold my breath long I was strong and
um
with that yeah so I had first of all
endured so many heavy poundings and then
I went into the glacier and got
desensitized from Fear after the glacier
it was a funny standing joke whenever I
kicked out of a wave in Tahiti where
it's the most death to find my boys
would be in the channel did you get the
rush and I'll be like not really a
little maybe not the real deal yeah no
so after 2007 I didn't I wasn't afraid
in the ocean anymore after the glacier I
literally was not afraid I I enjoyed all
the situations I'd I've got myself into
after that yeah the uh like thoroughly
enjoyed them just to just to paint the
picture though a little bit more
thoroughly the footage of you in Alaska
trying to Surf these waves that are
being created by the calving of these
glaciers is absolutely harrowing I mean
massive sheets of ice are just falling
off the sheer Cliffs of these gigantic
glaciers which are causing a tsunami
that you're there to ride right yeah it
is literally yeah and and you you have
to position yourself close enough to the
edge of the glacier in order to catch
that wave right and if the if the ice
falls directly down like in a sheath
it's all good but if it decides to tip
backwards and flat and land flat like a
pancake bookshelf is that what they call
it because it's the book you're you're
literally getting crushed like an ant is
that so the sense that that could be
possible at any moment was
and that's one of the few times where
you're like I'm out like that first day
there you're like this is not okay I
always visualize the positive outcome
and always work on being positive and
seeing success in that moment I
visualized being smashed like a tomato
is what I've been huh and that was just
yeah and even brought me even if you
survive that and you're riding the wave
there's gigantic pieces of ice
everywhere right like you I mean the
prospect that you would collide with one
of those is pretty high and they're
literally sharp cement floating
something yeah it would be just like
Greening into a brick wall yes yes I
mean like why it was really funny what
friends will talk you into doing and
yeah be careful with those friends tuck
you into right really you did end up
doing it that second day you were out
there doing it
I don't think things through too much I
just think I feel if it's a good idea or
not and then I go and then once I get
into what I've decided to do I'm like oh
still try to stay positive see the
positive it's a gut read it's a gut
inside yeah I'll get you know
um us generators
yeah there you go right but you know
this gets in you into trouble a little
bit like when you I think it was two was
it
2016 when you had spent a number of
Seasons at Nazareth but you're like I
want to go
surf these other breaks and be part of
this competition of Surfing the biggest
waves all over the world and kind of
travel a little bit more that lands you
back at Mavericks and the first wave out
where you took this crazy spill and end
up getting severely injured and sends
you down like you know a number of years
to kind of get well again
I couldn't help but think like
is there was there a little bit of of
ego in hubris like I've been surfing
Nazareth for a number of years now like
what's the big deal with Mavericks I can
go out here and do it no problem like
having a little bit too Cavalier of an
attitude and and lacking a little bit of
respect for Mother Nature
uh so I went out
a couple sessions before that one and it
was the most crowded day ever and I got
every single wave I wanted everybody
that's not in the series
it would have been nice but I just got
every people blown or blew blown away
because Nazareth you don't know where
it's gonna break and I've been surfing
that for five years all of a sudden I
show up at Mavericks
Peak go and I caught everywhere but I
was like in heaven I was like this is
too easy and uh so then I'm like okay I
want to begin this contest and so I went
back every time I went back two times
and then the third time was that January
just got back from Nazareth had a sore
neck going there for the wrong reasons
not for fun and not I mean I was going
for fun but I was thinking about getting
that contest getting invited how do I
get invited I gotta show a good showing
yeah they told you you couldn't do it
unless you showed up at Mavericks a
number of times and I've been trying to
put your reps in yeah so uh
wrong reason going there for a contest
instead of going there just for fun
right and not my neck was really sore
that day so I blew up my inflation vest
a little bit so I could actually rest on
it while I'm passing like a pillow
and uh board was a little too flat in
the tail
it should have more rocker it was I I
got these two waves that were 60 feet
the two previous swells
in and I expect and the Peter melwave
you know where the Peter Mel wave you
see that thing it was the best way I've
ever ridden at Mavericks I was searching
for that for years and for the two
sessions before the Wipeout I got one of
those
paddled started and then it doubled up
and I couldn't make it down so I'm
standing but I get kicked out the back
twice two different sessions so I'm like
I'm getting bigger board a heavier board
I'm going back there I'm getting that
wave that would have been a good story
to tell
bam yeah smack me down yeah a little
probably not as much
um well I have all the respect ultimate
respect
um I think the no fear
was a little bit that didn't make me as
um focused and cautious as maybe I could
be yeah more just like whatever just go
if I eat it no problem I don't don't
want to eat it but bring it on right so
you smash your shoulder yeah all kinds
of stuff right that really benched you
for a long time yeah still today I mean
Scar Tissue oh wow so you can't
straighten your left arm
I can but with help but it gets better
every day
yeah we're going to talk a little bit
about the yoga and all that kind of
stuff too
um before we kind of get into your your
backstory I do want to talk about the
100 foot wave uh phenomenon right like I
I guess I'm probably one of those people
who thought you surfed 100 foot wave
there's a lot of people out there that
just think of you as like oh that's the
guy who surfed the 100 foot wave because
that iconic famous photo probably the
most iconic big wave surfing photo ever
taken was you dropping in on this wave
that ultimately never really broke and
you kind of you know kind of surf out of
it on the left-hand side yeah but you
were on it long enough for that snap
that went around the world and the
mainstream news outlets all reporting
that you surfed 100 foot waves
drew a lot of attention to you yeah it
was uh the most beautiful picture I
think I've ever seen
um
and such a special moment we were I was
so focused I waited in the water for two
three hours for that way we we want is
that the big mama that's the right that
goes into this the safest wave if it's
over 80 under 80 the least the most
dangerous way because it goes straight
on the Rocks over 80 goes into the
channel breaks on that 60-foot shelf it
was almost broken to 60 and then kind of
came into the 40 and and just kind of
fizzled off into the thousand foot
Channel
so if they didn't show us at the end of
that wave I kicked out
and um Kaylee came to get me and missed
me and flew off the ski as well
then the second rescue came in
when by kle he's like and it went by
Kaylee and got me but I'm paddling this
little six foot twig that I can barely
paddle with all this flotation and and
the rocks are right there and I'm right
here and and this white the second wave
was bigger so the white water's coming
at me and I pushed the board and I swim
under
and I'm in this flotation suit that is
just too much flotation to swim under
and that almost and I would have slanted
right on the Rocks there was a GoPro
footage of that that wasn't shown either
would have been cool but but uh
that ride was very special but I was
very I was not happy at all when I
kicked out of that wave I was it was um
it was you know I just didn't do what I
wanted it to do right it wasn't a full
ride right and you even said like please
don't share those images I didn't really
ride this wave it was nonetheless they
leak out they go everywhere this creates
a huge media cycle around the whole
thing like I didn't even I never said it
was a hundred foot way how did that
become a thing the most challenging part
was Surfer Europe the photographer
tomane sent it to Surfer Europe and
Surfer Europe titles at McNamara claims
to have served
I mean when you look at it like does it
did it measure out to be a hundred foot
wave or no it depends who's measuring
but uh the top to the actual bottom with
the Curve 100 guaranteed 100 foot wave
but the from here to there I don't know
probably like 60 70.
so why didn't you fully write it why did
you decide to kick out uh it just ended
the Rocks were right there because it
wasn't it didn't break it just it was
one of those cross ones that don't
actually break the one behind broke
should have waited for the second one
yeah
um
wow man it's crazy uh I want to talk
about your upbringing it's so colorful
and and unique I mean you have this
you know truly original way in which you
were reared I mean almost feral as a
child
so talk a little bit I mean you were
born in Massachusetts but
um you really kind of grew up in
Berkeley paint a picture of you know
what a what a typical day was like for
you and your brother
well we when we showed up in Berkeley
People's Park Riot has just finished and
you know there's a lot of tension in the
air but it was just kind of subsiding
and I was just one and a half so I
didn't really know much except uh you
know there was like 20 people living in
this three-bedroom house and
my parents would go leave anytime they
wanted and I'd be home with some
babysitter who's not really a babysitter
just one of the hippies who was hanging
out and um so this was uh the commune
house that your mom started in Berkeley
it was the Gathering to get to commune
people right because the commune was in
Sonoma right Berkeley I mean I mean
cazadero yeah Sonoma County yeah so your
mom like inherited some money yep and
that was the goal like I'm gonna build a
community a hippie Community exactly and
she did really well I mean we had some
professors and there was people studying
us and it was uh
a really good group of people
um there were very free-spirited you
know everybody's running around naked
um taking whatever drugs they felt like
taking that day and doing whatever it
felt like doing on that day and um
it was super um I I really enjoyed those
those times
um it was just we were free
my wife always said you were basically
free from from one one and a half one
and a half they found me a mile down the
road Stoppers boarding school Upstate
New York they found me a mile down a
dirt road getting ready to enter the
highway in my diaper
and the cops pulled over grabbed me and
they call the house and they're like oh
you guys missing a girl and my mom
like girl no and if she looked oh that's
my check the diaper oh yeah it was a boy
how's my girl bring him home I broke I
just disappeared but she you know she
was always busy and
didn't really I mean we let her watch
our kids once in a while and we'll watch
from the window and she'll be going that
way and the kids are going oh yeah
there's a there's another word for that
that's less kind you know I mean
it's crazy that you know in today Child
Services would have been called and that
might have been that between you and
your mom I mean it's pretty neglectful
situation and and I don't think she
wasn't neglectful she was just very
self-absorbed right
there's another word for that too
it's interesting you know my sense is
that that
your mom whether it's narcissism or
neglect or just being consumed with her
own quest uh you know Find meaning in
her life or find God or whatever it is
uh you and your brother just didn't you
know really find that find find your way
onto her priority list in a in a healthy
way and every time you kind of
characterize your childhood because I've
listened to a number of interviews with
you you're always painting it in in
bright colorful language like it was fun
and we got to do what we wanted and you
know it was I have joyous memories of
all of that
um But Nicole's like yeah that's you
know there's another version of that
story like to me like this is this is
this is a traumatic experience that it
seems like you found a way to
compartmentalize or to process in your
own way and maybe that comes out in in
your surfing and in your you know quest
for adventure in these various ways but
I would imagine it was very difficult
with all the you know Adventures that
you went on with your parents
yeah the the 100 foot wave shows a bit
and it's interesting it's my favorite
number three is my favorite with all
that craziness but it's nothing compared
to what we went through there was it
barely scratched the surface and then
the book
The Hound of the sea
which shares a little but there's
nothing to scratch the surface so
when the feature film comes out I was
going to be uh
I was gonna is there a feature coming I
don't know I'm a man I'm a you know I'm
a generator so I can't go and add but if
somebody comes to me and wants to do a
feature I'll definitely entertain it but
they don't understand what's what's the
stories and the craziness and
just I mean it would be kind of if we
did it right it would be like R to the
match and just whacked out and right
people would blow their mind so so what
what is it about it that that hasn't
been told I mean you're so there's this
community in Berkeley ultimately there's
this commune and Sonoma
um at some point
this isn't doing it for your mom and she
wants to go to Mexico your dad wants to
stay you go with your mom your brother
gets left behind you end up on all these
crazy Adventures down you get left did
you get like you got left with a family
and a Mexican family yeah a Mexican
family Don Pepe and the family your mom
was off on her own going to pick up
money I think she was going to get money
or I don't know what she was doing she
was always always trying to figure out
how to pick up money from the
inheritance at some bank or somewhere or
and then always doing something
um yeah there was a lot of times when we
got left with different people mm-hmm
um but that was
by your recollection like a stable
healthy environment when you got left
with that family yeah it was really good
animals and you could have stayed there
I loved it they were just beautiful
Mexican family that had a ranch and so I
guess she felt really safe she would you
know I have to give my mom a lot of
credit she moved us to Hawaii she gave
us our free spirit she um
she loved us she would play music singer
sing put us up I mean she was a she was
good overall
um it was very unconventional but yeah
she was loving and she was a you know
just you know my wife now is a polar
opposite she is 100 present all the time
and uh so I got you know I think that's
what really attracted me to her is that
I was always looking for
my mama yeah well you could have very
well ended up marrying a version of your
mom I mean that's what a lot of people
do they speak out that same kind of
relationship again and the pattern
repeats itself so it feels like you
course corrected here and found the
healthy the healthiest type of
relationship that you could to kind of
mend that and you know sort of arrest
the the repetition of that unhealthy
cycle I just had the the podcast that
just went up this week is with this guy
Dr Gabor mate I don't know if you've
heard of him or followed any of his work
but it does sound familiar he's uh he he
he became prominent for his work around
addiction and recovery and this thesis
that he has that that
most addicts or addictions can be traced
back to unresolved or unhealed childhood
trauma and he's sort of more currently
extrapolated on that thesis to say that
so much of what ails us whether it's
physical or mental can be traced back to
unhealed trauma and that discussion
around trauma and how it
um
manifests in our lives and later in life
in terms of like behaviors that we
perpetuate or relationships that we get
involved in I think is is is really
profound and one of the things that he
helped me
um reckon with is this idea of of
um separating like when you look at how
you were parented right like I love my
mom and my dad or whatever and I don't
want to say anything bad about them but
he was able to help me understand like
you're not vilifying them like they did
the best that they could it doesn't mean
that they're bad people but that also
doesn't mean that you didn't incur
trauma because of decisions that they
made about how they parented you and I
feel like you're protecting your mom and
maybe there's an opportunity a growth
opportunity for you to really get into
some of what transpired when you were
younger
in a way that you can make peace with it
that would make you feel more whole
funny I
I always
um you know work on being positive and
but there was definitely things I held
on to
and I did uh
3.3 gram mushroom
medicine right I did four days in the
mountains doing the medicine wheel
uh it's a book where you go through and
work on all these different things that
apply to mostly your past and then you
go to through the you the met the the
mushroom the medicine isn't that isn't
required or necessary if you do the book
you can do it in your living room better
to go to the mountains and away from
everybody that's what I did but uh then
I did a 3.3 gram Journey
I let go of everything said Thank you to
it all and it's like yeah I'm so
feel so light and so good and none of it
is holding me back or taking me down or
Weighing on me it's all I've
I've had a nice uh conversation thank
you not serving me anymore
love you that's great good for you man
did you do that under supervision or
just read this book and decided to do a
DIY trip a good friend of mine Eric nice
he uh shared the book with me and then
he flew over and guided the
the journey right wow how long ago was
that
three months ago what three or four it
was recent
wow wow
um but that was a breakthrough for you
oh visiting all these things that are
just stuck letting them go loving that
choosing to love them all was the key
choosing to love all those situations
all those challenging moments all those
life experiences that you might
categorize like ah I love you thank you
right
you got me where I am today I love you
thank you I wouldn't be right here now
that's true all of these experiences are
cohere to create you know this this
incredible hero's journey that you've
been on
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with them
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
picking up where we left off so so
you end up in Hawaii at some point Liam
comes but your brother is back in the
picture right like you and your mom and
your brother all go together yeah to the
North Shore yep because she hooked up
with some other dude or there's a
stepdad involved or what was happening a
musician a black musician His Name Was
Daryl and we tried to go to Florida like
two or three times first when we jump in
the car you place an ad and somebody
okay yeah come drive with me some whack
job like weirdo we jump out quick like
couple miles down the road I think this
happened twice going to Florida and then
over going to Hawaii
there are all of our friends throw this
big party for us oh sorry we can't go
finally Daryl actually gets us to Hawaii
through Daryl we got to Hawaii
and uh we end up on the North Shore and
probably the I mean we're in Hawaii on
the North Shore but we're in the least
desired spot called Cement City right so
it's kind of uh like affordable housing
project type apartment buildings yes and
we were you know Daryl was a musician
and he actually worked with Don Ho's uh
daughter and he was he he was good and
then he left as soon as we got there so
then we're on welfare and
government assistance and this and my
mom was just depressed and you're like
what 12 11 11. I went to first year of
Elementary was one of the only white boy
in the class and
all Filipinos and Hawaiians and um and
and you basically didn't really go to
school though right like you'd go on the
front door and out the back door that
was during Elementary in in California
oh wow I never went to school
we would go to UC Berkeley every day and
hang out on the campus from five to no
from like
at Berkeley we you know like six or
seven to eleven never went to school we
would literally go climb the fire fire
escape of these buildings and go pull
all the marijuana plants and go home and
roll fat George worked for you know 10
years old so you're we're rolling fast
oh my God we ate peyote up there and uh
I ate peyote was about five was that
because your dad was running a
vegetarian restaurant he was serving it
at the restaurant is that true he wasn't
serving pot he but he had um it was my
goodness Cafe on a [__] Attic in Ashby
uh-huh right in the thick of it yeah
when we were on Emerson the two Block
Street it was right back from one block
back from Shattuck and Ashby holy Foods
was on the corner I don't know if it
turned into Whole Foods but it was holy
Foods
uh yeah so
yeah we were wild and we were free and
we did whatever we wanted we would stay
out till 12 to whatever from 7 to 11 we
were free there was uh the serial killer
was on like killing right now we moved
out there until that was was that zodiac
era I think so I don't know which one it
was but we were out when he was out
uh-huh we were supposed to be
uh it's total insanity it reminds me of
uh now imagine the the to put that into
a yeah I mean yeah it's like have you
read flee's book Ask it for the children
I would just looking at that yeah I have
it right over there you should read that
book I mean it's pretty similar I mean
he was a feral kid and he had you know
kind of a chaotic you know family
situation but he was just running wild
on the streets of LA at a very young age
you know it's it's a it's a version of
your story and in some yeah we skimmed
the surface on
I mean you paint those pictures of
killers over there on the left and
you're over here on the right shooting
off rockets that you stole the date that
day
right all right so you're in Hawaii
Elementary School
some at some point a surfboard gets
introduced to you I mean you're on the
North Shore it's almost inevitable
that you're going to end up in the waves
we were super lucky normally a holly who
enters a school
you're gonna get beat and it's not going
to be fun I got super lucky first let's
go had a fight with this one guy and
got him good and then the naughtiest
guys in the school came and we were best
friends and we made a gang we had our
leather jackets I we we yeah it was
funny and then the person who calls in
the office and says oh no gangs in my
school takes our leather jackets but uh
sorry the question where were we going
surfboard surfboard mom goes to a garage
sale and buys a board for 15 bucks and
brings it home and uh that was our board
it was like 12 feet long about 50 60
pounds and think in the book it says we
found it in the bushes yeah there's a
lot of different my brother said that my
brother remembers everything my brother
Liam and and it was like a love at first
sight type of Deal or what how did the
you know relationship with surfing kind
of flourish from there well the first
encounter was with our best friend
Butchie boy and his dad had a bunch of
kneeboards these beautiful artwork on
these kneeboards on the wall and then it
was his birthday and he's said oh come
we'll go surfing my dad's kneeboards and
we went out we weren't about to stay on
our knees so we went straight to our
feet fell in love that was it nothing
mattered on the land whatever was going
on the land
disappeared during the water you got
shorts warm water surfboard
need no you're just in heaven it was too
good it would consumed us and became our
passion became our love became my
everything it was a bit took Liam a few
more years he loved baseball and he was
already being scouted by the uh was
scouting him and oh wow yeah yeah and I
I didn't realize that initially he's the
surf star
oh for 10 years the guy like he was a
big deal big he made as much more money
than every anybody for about 10 years
and
he made money for at least
a whole of 20 maybe 25 years good money
right he's your younger brother yeah
yeah and so he's getting all these
accolades he's on the cover of all the
magazines he's taken home prize money
but ultimately like he he becomes a
victim of his own Character defects
right like he's a hothead and ultimately
ends up like making a lot of enemies at
least that's the way the narrative is
spun in the docu-series
he was uh he didn't back down
he ruled Rocky Point and did his best to
rule pipeline just best to rule both
those spots those two spots were the
most photographed spots in the world he
got more waves than anybody guaranteed
for 10 years so he had a really good
career just based on piping Rockies we
loved going to Japan we go to Australia
I would kind of be in his shadow get to
go along once in a while and try and
surf in the contest I never did any good
he would always
kind of he would do you know he was a
fierce competitor he was gonna beat you
you have to get three waves in 20
minutes he's gonna pal around you and
take that the best three waves of the
heat possibly right he's not gonna let
you get anywhere he forget the etiquette
and the decorum but there was none when
it came to those Heats all the boys all
the Surfers
it was doggy dog and you're not friends
once you get that heat nowadays it's a
little different
they're a little more friendly until the
ant oh the priority
it's just there's real rules now with
the priority so
but uh back then it was yeah if you're
Hawaiian or you're from Hawaii you had
an edge because all the Surfers around
the world want to go to Hawaii and if
you're a badass and you hung with the
boys you're one of the boys when they
come to Hawaii they're going to get sent
home if they mess with you anywhere else
so even in these Heats in Japan
and he's being rewarded for that
behavior until he's the bad boy of
Surfing yeah until the Magazine's
blackballed him and
the judges started giving him 0.5 less
always he if he was going to win a heat
he had to really win it like there was a
pipe Masters that he I think he won I'd
like to watch the tapes again but they
scored Kelly Stater 0.5 higher on each
wave and scored him a 0.5 lower on each
wave
and um yeah and ultimately at some point
you start catching up to him so what was
going on how are you able to
no longer be the older brother in the
wake of his younger brother and surpass
him it's funny because I'm still
I'm really no longer in the Wake but
once in a while I'll meet somebody who
knows Liam or knows of Liam and didn't
know me and they're like whoa you guys
are totally opposite
but uh
toe surfing
I started toe surfing to get away from
all the crowds there's so many crowds
and layered and Buzzy and Derek show up
with their jet zodiac and I saw and so I
ran home I got my board I'm sitting at
Sunset with my 10-foot board and I'm
about to paddle out there to ask them to
tow me into one and this was the first
very very first experiment with this
Buzzy kerbox and yeah that original OG
2N crew and I sat on the beach with my
jaw like but you know those cartoon
characters when the jaw drops to the
ground
and we're just watching and then I from
then on I was obsessed I bought a zodiac
painted giant shark mouth on it tried to
do it my zodiac
it was uh and then my friends got a
Sea-Doo jet boat Charlie Walker and
Dawson Jones got this uh pontoon so uh
zetski with a pontoon basically and they
brought me in and that was it that was
it so it went from I'm never gonna be a
big wave surfer that wasn't cool too
it's all about big waves now well no I I
actually was
from till 16 I was scared to death the
big waves I was not going to surf away
over 10 feet 10 feet face and then after
16 I I fell in love with big waves a
friend made me go out when I did not
want to and gave me the right board gave
me the right advice and I got everywhere
I wanted so I lived for a big way from
that day forward but
it was a my career was based around
Japanese sponsors pretty much a couple
USA sponsors
and then uh
I loved big waves but there wasn't much
there for a big wave surfer you know it
wasn't really these Soul Surfers or free
Surfers but I like call a Soul Surfer
and I made a little money like 500 a
month maybe 1500 at the most for all
these years I had to rent rooms to pay
for the pay the bills and in my house
and then uh toe surfing was to get away
from everybody and all of a sudden it
became this cool sport that actually
everybody
was interested in because you know all
of us have had an experience in the
water a traumatic experience in the
water whether it's a bathtub a lake a
river an ocean sometime throughout our
life most all humans have had a
traumatic we have utmost respect for
waves and then big waves
like
how and so they're just captivated and
interested so all of a sudden this has
energy around this thing yeah that you
had been into just for the pure joy of
it not because like oh there's a way to
be Pro and a way to support myself doing
this so you become the guy who is
working to live right like it's just I
gotta make enough money so that I can go
surf the waves I want to surf the money
was more for the family when I got the
job when I saw it was just kind of like
our kids so just to stay home and take
care of the kids and hopefully take them
all on a trip right so you open up this
store on the North Shore was it a surf
shop what kind of yeah it was called
Epic Sports and it was a surf shop but
it was uh there was a little bit of MMA
stuff in there that bad boy was my
partner and sponsor and that and that's
between how old are you during this
period
of 35
yeah I think about 35 is when I actually
oh wait it was 35 was when I closed the
store it was
um 30 to 32 to 35 right so for three
years okay you know I'm not gonna go
work in a cubicle I'm going to be a
little bit of a small business
entrepreneur at least I can control some
aspect of my desktop oh I was create an
epic Empire it was not going to be oh
really a huge worldwide right so this is
this is franchises of this store all
over the world surfing meets MMA yeah up
Epic Sports all right
um but you know quickly you become a bit
of a working stiff right who's like
driving by the waves on the way to work
and and you know kind of living this
life of quiet resignation
yeah I gave up on my passion opened that
store and
quiet was the word and
you're doing to support your family yeah
pay the bills and you know be
responsible adult you that's what I
thought but it definitely brought me
to become somewhat depressed
and just because I would drive by these
perfect waves every day going to work
and I'd be like I'm going to work and
I'm gonna wave
mm-hmm
yeah I see a lot of myself in this story
I mean the facts of my you know
narrative are quite different but you
know I had my version of that like at at
40 this existential kind of Crisis about
what I was doing how I was spending my
time the choices that I had made about
how to make a living and just being
deeply unhappy with all of that but also
feeling feeling very confused about how
to resolve that right so walk me you
know in your version of of this story
like what was the Tipping Point or what
you know what what occurred to lead you
to this place of saying I I can't do
this anymore like there's something else
something bigger something better out
there for me if you don't mind I'd like
to know your Tipping Point oh well I
gotta I'll give you this book but I had
I mean
mine was you know mine came in the form
of a little bit of a health scare that
coincided with
um
with this you know kind of low-grade
depression about
um
about you know where I was in my life
and that created a little bit of a
perfect storm and my resolution began
with just changing my relationship to
myself first through food and then
through movement and that very slowly
kind of led me in a New Direction so it
was a it wasn't like a like a lightning
bolt kind of thing where everything
changed quickly it was a very gradual
shift
well interesting I'm going to get that
book yeah okay
definitely yeah this is about you bro
okay so uh
going driving to the store perfect waves
gotta go work that was where it was like
uh and and I started drinking coffee at
35.
or 33. when I opened the store the first
time I started drinking coffee
meaning like for the first time in your
life you needed something
external exogenous to excite you or give
you energy yep whereas prior to that you
never needed that nope
and so uh we get to the store and I
remembered okay I wrote a business plan
for this store I got that businessman
for dummies but again and made a
business plan for the store and I'm like
oh let's see if we can do that to keep
surfing so I put on the keep surfing the
goals when the Eddie win the Jaws how do
I do that I eat very you know the eating
program the training program the
manifesting visualizing
and um did that for from that day since
I wrote that plan
and uh
focused put so much time and I have put
it on the refrigerator I put in the car
I put in the bathroom mirror I
uh the the map
the blueprint to achieve these goals so
there was Clarity though you knew okay I
gotta get back to surfing how am I going
to do that I've got a family I've got
bills well Jaws uh Eddie those are
contests with prize money right so the
quickest way to put money in the bank
account is to win one of those how am I
going to win one of those in the short
term and then long term it becomes about
sponsors and all of that right so is
that what the business plan look like
like I'm interested in like what were
the line items you know in the business
plan and how did those translate into
sticky notes with specific goals or or
mantras that were going to lead you in
that direction
it was the uh
the winning was everything
because with that would come the
sponsors and the partners
[Music]
and did you have a history of winning
competitions where you knew that that
was a feasible possibility or was that
more like a pipe train to win a big
conference
surfing why man more than anybody
up to the store
I had been Towing I I was real confident
that I was going to win I knew that
Eddie I was winning there was no doubt
in my mind
and the Jaws I thought I could win that
as well until I went there after writing
my goals I went there for the first time
they called the contest on and it was
windy and small so they canceled it but
we went out and towed it for the first
time and it was terrifying so powerful
so and I was like oh Josh I'm winning
the Eddie I just want to come home in
Maui at the Jaws I just want to come
home right so so for people that don't
know Jaws is the huge wave on Maui it's
the one that Laird kind of made famous
and told us was there this was at the
time when there was it was all about
Jaws right because Laird was there and
that was that was the nazare of that
moment yes yeah and Eddie is North Shore
Oahu so that's your backyard that's
literally my I can see it from my friend
right so it would make sense oh well
Eddie is is probably the better
opportunity for you because you know it
so well
contest day arrives
they call both of them on same day they
don't have we don't have the computers
uh looking at the buoys you had to call
every hour to see where the buoys are at
because that's how you know how big the
waves are going to be and I'm literally
calling every hour checking the boys
checking the boys all the way I'd sleep
a little bit call sleep a little closer
4 A.M
I was
still undecided I have my partner
Rodrigo Zander my teammate on Maui
waiting and I was in the Eddy the
previous year I'm the only Surfer in
history that I was number nine alternate
and uh number nine didn't come and I'm
paddling out Elijah young didn't show
this is it Eddie I'm paddling out in the
Eddie I get out there
Elijah makes it paddles out Garrett you
gotta paddle in meaning you're out you
can't compete
right devastated Beyond but okay but the
universe has another planet
right so I'm still and now I'm seventh
alternate not ninth and um
yeah I just couldn't see myself sitting
on that beach not knowing if I could
surf or not and the main thing is I had
my teammate waiting for me so at 4am I
rushed to the airport got on the plane
and went shot over to Maui yeah right
and said let's drop in here what was the
difference in prize money between Eddie
and Jaws well Eddie was I don't know
like 20 grand or something like that oh
maybe 50 it was
it was the Eddie was could have been
kind of high back then but Eddie was
kind of the more most precise
yeah that's his last name right Eddie in
honor of this legendary Surfer and that
was like the prestigious one to win
Eddie I caught Invitational the one we
all big wave Surfers dream to be in it's
like the Pinnacle
and uh but the Jaws is the first Jaws
are the first of its kind but they had
seventy thousand dollars prize money
more prize money but you're less
experienced on this wave you would never
surf this wave before and my partner
forget this heesh never towed before so
he shows up on Oahu this is not looking
good he shows up on Oahu and I tell okay
let's go practice so I take them over to
This Little Wave It's called um police
Beach and it's this little teeny wave
that's about this tall maybe a little
bigger but it breaks just like Jaws a
nice right to go in the channel and left
it's kind of gnarly and I tell them just
put me on that right and it's this big
and he puts me exactly on the way
perfect and I'm like oh we got this
don't worry he's like what the [__] are
you talking about I mean we got it we
got it don't worry because I I mean I
had my plan I knew how to win I knew
what to do and I shared with him and we
focused and we didn't train that much
and but I knew that he just had to put
me on the wave the rescue guys will pick
me up so he would put me on the way if
we ask you guys would get me and he was
like a shark he was a badass like he was
So Into You know I was sharing some
people will never learn and other people
learned quick I was a slow learner it
took me a while to get good this guy was
good instantly so um and he surfed
better and every he was more focused
than any big wave surfer at that time
for paddling so you go to jaws and you
feel confident but it wasn't like there
was an expectation that you were going
to win this competition right who were
the who were the people that were
expected oh they were all there Parsons
and Gerlach and all the Maui boys I mean
yeah it was that was a really good solid
showing uh-huh but yeah definitely none
of them were probably thinking about me
and Rodrigo right and you're how old 30
35 35 right so not exactly in the prime
of your
physical career as a professional
athlete okay what are you talking about
I know we're going to get to that part
like it's all love Garrett listen you
know I didn't I didn't start getting
into my athletic stuff into my 40s so oh
wow um all right so long story short you
end up winning this competition like
when you think back on that I mean two
questions first
um
what was it that you did that allowed
you to win like what was the secret
sauce in that Victory and then perhaps
more importantly like what do you what
do you make of that in retrospect
looking back you know at the Arc of your
story and kind of everything that's
transpired as a result because that this
is another huge inflection point that
sets up the ability for you to have a
life as a surfer and go on to do all
these other things
first of all we had a magic 7-2 Brewer
and from last surfboard yeah from Laird
and them you know working with dick they
made what was the best at that time and
I was lucky enough to tap into that
specific four Jaws yes but but didn't
everybody have that board or no they all
had versions their own version but seven
two that was long we're on six O's now
it was still dinosaur
right and everybody had dinosaurs but
they all had the similar dinosaurs
uh compared to what we're on now
but so um I sat him down I said look
we're he went first for I think it was
like 45 minutes 30 30 45 minutes and
then I we had half half of the heat was
me happy it was him
put I said look we're making you make
three waves no matter what I'm putting
you in a safe enough spot
so you can make the waves I'm Rob was a
really good driver already so I put him
in a safe zone so he could make the
waves he made it so you're after you
make three waves you can then we'll get
barreled that was the goal then pull in
but until you make three wave don't even
think about pulling in
so he made his three waves fourth wave
he pulled in it got he it kind of
clamped on the top and he got and I went
in to pick him up
and uh he jumps on the sled and this
wave is coming in it's all foaming a ski
he's not going
like stuck in mud and this massive wave
is coming and then it's the selfless guy
that he is he look he and he was already
beat from that first one he was tired he
pushes the sled
as the wave Catches Us and then
the ski goes up 10 50 maybe 20 feet high
I'm up there and I'm just like there's
none there's no way you can come out of
this but I I got my feet in these foot
straps I got my hand on how much my
number one first sponsor ever it was his
jet ski by chance he'd let us use it and
um
I'm about to bail but I just kept
holding it flew me out in front just
landed pop
I mean that was the hand of God if there
ever was a hand of God that was it
so basically what you're saying is he
put you by hook or by Crook and and the
most unlikely situation you ended up
exactly where you needed to be to get
this wave and have this ride of your
life well him he got away so he got the
three good waves so the way it works is
you alternate surfing and towing with
your partner yes right so it's a two-man
gig yes and you're getting scored
as you know how you kind of do
collectively as a team so those three
waves each right and then the purse you
split versus or it depends on what you
do agree on you know I won't ask you
whatever that was split
um and ultimately you end up becoming
victorious in this in this event uh in
an unlikely way I'm sure people were
surprised like this 35 year old guy who
had seemingly retired suddenly is back
um what did the surfing World make of
that at the time
uh not much no they swept under the rug
and they kind of made it like Parsons
girl like William's brother had kind of
a thing but like we don't need to pay
too much attention to that well plus I'm
even further yeah but Parsons got the
best wave of the contest is crazy wave
and made it and uh they just really
pumped that up and all the surf media in
Brazil it was a big thing just Brazil me
and Rodrigo won Studio Amigos the
sponsor Global TV the biggest Network
it's going on prime time so we I was
huge in Brazil the rest of the surfing
world still didn't really know much and
the sponsors didn't start flying in and
I thought to myself okay well now I'm
going to Tahiti and I'm gonna go get
something big there and we went and I
got a cover on Surfer and then of course
I won the contest you know they knew of
the word oh but nobody oh well who is
this then go to Tahiti get this freaking
incredible wave that's Grace is the
cover of
all kinds of magazines all over the
world and then I'm gonna kick so I was
watching the boys at jaws and I'm just
like what the hell are they doing on why
aren't they in the barrel and then I
went there that first time I was like oh
now I know why they're not the barrel
this wave is it's Jaws it's trying to
eat you and it's not nothing to play
around with and now I know why but I I
understood why but I still wanted to go
get barreled there so I went that next
winter 2003
got the barrel so now I guess you're the
first guy to get barreled at jaws I
don't know about the freaking Barrel but
I got a a really good one and um so I
got the win then I got Tahiti and then I
got the barrel
the funny thing about the barrel is they
put on the cover it's me but it says
Laird and Company so I get it's like so
I could only imagine people going all
right how's that barrel and going oh
yeah
yeah it was it was it's a trip right
yeah so then um
but the sponsor started coming I got on
I was working with Red Bull a little bit
since I had the store and they were
coming all in and then uh
then had a manager came in right there
and made me a website and then um we got
I was with Excel the manager screwed
that deal
um yeah things were I had this manager
who wasn't in Surf he was a senior vice
president of Time Warner in marketing
and production and he retired and and
then took me on as his main project so I
learned everything I know nothing I mean
I was a surfer that did not want his
face did not want his name did not want
anything don't want to talk about what I
just did just
mm-hmm and he's like you got to make a
poster Garrett McNamara you gotta do
this
well it was a there's a convergence of a
couple things happening here I mean
first of all culturally within surfing
it's not cool to promote yourself it
never had been it was you know the punk
rock of it all was to just go out and
surf ways for the joy of it if anybody's
paying attention fine but but you're not
going to be the guy out there throwing
stuff up on social media but that's
because social media didn't exist and
also you know carving out a career
outside of the very narrow scope of what
it meant to be a pro conservative Surfer
was starting to change and with with the
Advent of these new surfing Technologies
and towing surfing and all the
experimentation that was kind of being
led by Laird and his cohort of of surf
Renegades suddenly and and then with
social media kind of being layered on
top of that there was this sense of
possibility like you could craft or
carve out a career that lived outside of
those traditional Notions of how to make
a living but that meant that you had to
be not necessarily Shameless but you had
to be in control of your own kind of
promotional engine and responsible for
getting the word out about what you were
doing because you know ultimately the
you you have the responsibility to
shoulder like getting sponsors and all
of that manager or no manager yeah Laird
was the OG the guru the guy who broke
out of the surfing and went to and it
was possible and I really
watched and learned
and really um embraced how he did things
and so when this senior vice president
guys telling me I just had the other
thing I'm like okay okay okay not what I
want to do but that's what they're doing
so we'll do it but so
and that's what yeah it was from there
you know the doors just opened they
started knocking on my door I didn't
have to knock on doors it was it was
amazing it was the first time in my life
I wasn't yeah he sponsored me it was
right but the business plan's working
business plan work yeah you are you're
manifesting you're generating it's all
happening you're able to pay the bills
it's all about that goal and that
blueprint it works but you know what the
number one thing in in all of our um
sports or careers or whatever is carving
out a niche because a niche has
longevity you you might not be the best
for more than a year or two but if you
have a little niche you're the
you're the yogi of this or you're the
Jack Johnson or you're the photographer
or you're still in the world you're
still in surfing but vicariously through
this Niche that you carved out
so you were conscious of that and what
what how would you define the the niche
that you were carving out or attempting
to carve out at that time
I was just
the guy who would just
put it on the line bulletproof I mean my
friends would call me bulletproof and I
felt bulletproof and I had a little
flotation that nobody else had so I was
telling me a little Innovation they
didn't realize they didn't they were all
right what do you do with that they're
laughing and going and I'm going to but
anyway please come pound me no problem
I'm coming up uh-huh and so they thought
I was kind of crazy they didn't realize
it was calculated crazy and at what
point I mean your your first marriage
ends up for dissolving right around this
time yep what was going on there uh
lack of support
um lack of trust
and rightfully so I wasn't in the best
place
yeah
um
uh and you got you that first marriage I
mean you got married really young yeah
yeah yeah
um and what's your relationship to like
drugs and alcohol and all of that I mean
you had this crazy childhood where it
seemed like it was omnipresent but did
you grow out of that or was that still
part of your
world at that time I smoked pot from 12
to 22.
stopped in 89.
um never really liked the taste of
alcohol but
loved a good party
loved uh you know a couple with crumbs
with lime tastes good and with some
tequila and then you're having I mean
you're right Irish yeah yeah then you're
having a great time
uh to be honest cocaine was something
that we played with a little bit when we
were really young we my brother and I
got into it and then I went to Japan
when I was 19 and saw that I could have
a career and then that's when I put pot
put everything and then got my brother
too and
um I slowly got sucked back into cocaine
a bit
and it wasn't wasn't pretty to be honest
at all it wasn't a party anymore it was
just like dark and was that when you
were depressed getting depressed yeah
when you're at the store yeah yeah there
was things that led up to it I mean if I
went back probably
some childhood things but more
things that happen in my relationship
with my wife that really depressed made
me bummed out about our relationship
because of things that she did so uh
I would probably that was probably what
really I mean I can't blame anybody I
take full responsibility I chose to you
know I chose it I I
so it was all me
um was there things that
definitely wait on me would that I let
way on me yeah now I'm choosing not to
let anything win I mean love it all yeah
so it sounds like a lot of the use was
kind of situational or environmental
like when you make these made these
decisions at different times to like
walk away from it you were able to do
that so you never went down some
like rampant addiction Rabbit Hole or
anything like that you were able to kind
of put it in the rear view when you
needed to or need to it's funny because
I would on my birthday August 10th I
would have one last big party and then I
would train and until I accomplished
something really huge and then sell it
and then in my party again and that
might go for the rest of the until my
birthday again is that still going on or
no no I've been since I met Nicole I've
been just well let's talk about Nicole
like that's the other huge inflection
point so the inflection points that that
like I'm trying to like like map it out
like you have uh you know moving to
Hawaii of course and then you know
there's winning Jaws like these kind of
pivotal moments in your life but
certainly I don't I don't see any more
important or Monumental pivotal moment
in your life that uh exceeds meeting
Nicole and kind of how
um the impact that that she has had and
this relationship has had on on like how
you are not just on your surfing but
like how you are as a man and and you
know what you value and what you're you
know choosing to uh invest your time in
ETC so talk a little bit about meeting
her and kind of what this relationship
has
meant to you
well it's funny you know the the cartoon
character I was when I saw Laird in them
with my jaw on the floor and
when I saw her it was like the cartoon
character that gets levitates and drags
across by his toes to her yeah it was
just love at first sight and it was um
yeah I was just captivated by her
her
being her beauty her present just being
her you know you're full she's so
present and
so inspiring and so uh everything that
I've dreamed everything that I dreamed
of him in a in a partner a life partner
it was she was right there in front of
me and you guys met in Costa Rica
Puerto Rico Puerto Rico at uh surface
healing Uncle Lizzy pascowitz I was
supporting his uh surface healing event
in Puerto Rico and she was there at the
charity dinner
the night before helping with the flower
arrangements through her dad's friend
who was doing the fire Arrangements she
was there for a race she was a badass
paddler she's like
and um we met and that was it and that
was there's nothing that would stop at
eight or something like that how long
nine or ten ten ten ten so shortly after
you guys met that you ended up in
Nazareth then I didn't realize that
timeline was so compressed yeah wow
wow she comes into your life and then
suddenly you guys are in Portugal oh we
went on the most amazing journey ever we
lived out of a suitcase for three years
uh-huh and it was the best time of our
life it's our life is still like too
good I'm like pinch me I can't even
believe where we're at right now but
that was the most
um
we were just
present and together and I mean
as she says I held on to her every word
I was that you know anything and
everything she wanted at all time and
the same her for me and
that was before the kids I think you
know like I can't help but like try to
compare your story to my story and I
don't want to make it about me but you
know I have a similar I I've had a very
similar experience in many ways
um and there's something about my
relationship with my wife who's very
different from me
um that creates a certain kind of
powerful Alchemy and I see that in your
relationship like the sum of the two of
you together is much greater than the
sum of its parts right because of this
partnership and what you each bring to
this equation you've been able to you
know accomplish things and manifest
things that you know I'm sure exceed
what you would have thought possible for
yourself
yeah literally since we've joined forces
we literally
strongly without a doubt feel that we
can pretty much do anything we want like
anything there's nothing that we can't
do if we want if we put our mind to it
yeah and where does that come from
foreign
well you know the secret and then
I've read uh I've been into Deepak
Chopra seven spiritual Laws of Success
sure but it really comes from
she's very organized
and um
I think most of all it's because all of
our the things that we focus on are more
selfless and somehow we want to give
back with whatever we're doing when you
have that aspect to it all you really
can't fail I mean you know you get the
goal you get the plan you get the road
map but you have a selfless approach to
it that's the secret sauce and
everything if you're in a mindset and
have a plan to be giving more than
you're receiving or looking to receive
uh for me that's always been a recipe
for
manifesting things even larger than what
you imagined
I I like that I I have to yes I agree
with that one you're the doer and you're
the dreamer uh Nicole is very much the
structure and the feedback loop and the
accountability piece projector projector
human design that's another podcast
she's badass she she does it like she
has a line of people that want it so bad
oh cool but she yeah I very rarely does
run I love it she's really good but I
wanna I wanna like kind of double click
on this and and really try to
deconstruct this process uh for for
people that are listening or watching
you know everybody has a dream or
something they're trying to accomplish
or a goal that feels a little bit Out Of
Reach and it's easy to make excuses or
to construct reasons why it's not
rational or reasonable or possible
um so help me to better understand like
the mechanics of your goal setting
process
the mantras the manifestations like what
does that look like in terms of you know
how your
going about your day
well the
the mantras loving kind and helpful
and if we're loving kind and helpful all
day long I mean
you're gonna feel great because
everybody around you is going to be feel
great and everything's going to unfold
as it should
I've I've been uh
you know I like to get up really early
and do my little meditation and and when
we're really on point like in the first
I'd say five years maybe even longer we
would wake up together every morning we
would
do our little
um meditation then we'd write down what
we want to work on personal growth and
what we want to work on career and
and then we would actually
manifest meditate that's a daily thing
yeah together a specific answer to those
respective questions yeah right the out
conversation the actual outcome see
yourself where you where that goal leads
you mm-hmm
live in that reality feel it right to
your bones because you can't experience
it if you're not visualizing it then
um how is it going to be possible right
that's the idea and don't be too rigid
be attached to
the end game let it more if it if it
wants to
let it go this way or that way
don't be too rigidly attached to the
outcome so this is a daily practice you
do this in the morning at night morning
we were doing a morning just morning to
a night at it sometime right see I
invited Nicole to sit in on this I'm
thinking that's the better I can go get
her over here and she didn't want to do
it the baby no she is the best you want
to come in for this part yeah come on in
as long as the baby is okay you know
that baby's a dream should we just sit
there set up the extra mic really quick
we'll just like take a beat here
I knew we needed to have Nicole on right
I'm so glad you're joining us thank you
for having me thanks it's an honor so uh
I think we this is like this is the
juice this is the best part of the
podcast I want to get deep on the
mindset techniques and the manifesting
and
um the dream weaving all the mystical
energy that gets injected into you know
what's what's required to like Chase an
audacious goal especially when it feels
like the world is lined up against you
true it's a good stuff Magic
and it is a little bit of magic I think
you have to have that belief that and
you you have to believe that anything is
possible you know and today's
world it's almost like they don't want
us to accomplish our dreams you know
they fill our days with distractions and
and also maybe uh a disbelief in that
you have to be a certain way to be
successful and that's just not true and
that's the beauty about human design
which we've mentioned a couple of times
is that you know human design is all
about deconditioning yourself back to
your authentic being
so that you can really your energetic
Aura can be inviting the universe to
send you what you right are really meant
to have and you can be fully expressed
in what you're naturally inclined to do
right yeah you don't have to wake up at
5am if that's not what you're meant to
do to be successful you can still be
successful without
being exhausted wait what you're gonna
wake up at 5am well you're a generator
you're meant to right now with all these
like here's the morning routine that's
what you need to be successful well like
first understand thyself like how are
you wired not everybody is wired the
same exactly it's super important my
family is is is all generators except
our youngest is a uh is a is a
I can't remember whether he's a
projector or a reflector but in either
case it's a totally different energy
totally different to somebody who needs
a lot of alone time can go out in the
world but then has to go decompress
decompress it's really important you
know it has to be invited into things
and as opposed to going out and chasing
things and it's just a different wiring
and like understanding that allows us as
parents to figure out a better means to
support that type of energetic system it
really changes the parenting game yeah
absolutely and another thing is also I
think it's super important who you
surround yourself with when you have
these dreams and these goals you know
your your team and your team is everyone
you surround yourself with it's not just
your team it's you know your friends
it's your family it's anyone you choose
to surround yourself with you know
they're they're part of your journey and
you have to be with people who really
believe in you and when you have these
goals with these
road map
or yeah
what what do we call it a road map or a
blueprint a blueprint
um it's really important to understand
that every second of every day that you
spend not on what's on that map it will
take you further away from your goal
right it's knowing that
every word we speak is a choice
everything we consume in our on our
phones on the TV on our computers and
our body our food is bringing us closer
right or farther away nothing static
everything is in flux so every decision
that you make every interaction that you
have every thought that you entertain
every word that comes out of your mouth
is moving you towards the thing that you
aspire to achieve or be or away from it
and when you can root yourself in the
moment and really appreciate that it
really helps drive a better decision
tree and helps you to say no to the
things that aren't serving you Etc but
you have to overcome all your kind of
default programming for sure there's a
lot of work to be done you know like all
this other noise that gets in the way
right and we like to say that we are by
no means the best now but we're always
working on it and we're always working
to better ourselves in our lives and our
team and in the world but going back to
real tools that you can do it's you know
so here you are wanting every choice you
make throughout the day to be bringing
you closer to these goals you have so
what really helps is you know you're
making this blueprint up here's my goal
this is what I need to do and as Garrett
said you know he put it everywhere so if
you walk into our bathroom on the mirror
Expo marker you know you have your
mantras written you have your goal
written you get in your car have a
little sticky note like a great way to
do it is take your blueprint take a
picture of it and make it your
your home screen put it on your home
screen on your phone which you look at a
million times exactly so it the more you
see it the more you're feeling it and
plus the easier it'll be to make the the
decisions that are getting you closer
yeah so Garrett I know that you've said
that you're not an adrenaline junkie
but clearly you have a certain kind of
unique relationship with brisk and
adventure and I know Nicole has said
that like the the riskiest thing you've
ever done is get involved with this guy
Garrett right your relationship with
risk is different maybe on a
relationship level like you have a high
risk uh you know sort of no no tolerance
because you well you got involved with
him so you know you're going on some
crazy adventure you didn't you didn't
meet her father well I saw it well I saw
him I'm like that guy looks like a
character all right you're the best
character that's the only way to
describe it on this character but I
really you had the most beautiful
description of our relationship that
I've ever heard is that you know the
Alchemy of it and you know I I always
say you know that we were brought
together for a reason it gets really
clear that we're together because we can
do great you know help the world a
little bit and when we started the
documentary you know I told them I was
like look we'll do this but there is no
way that I'm making a surf movie like if
you guys have any desire to make a surf
movie we're out of here the only way I'm
doing this and US putting our time in it
if it's inspiring like I want people to
walk away knowing that it truly is it's
like never too early and never too late
to follow your dreams and on top of that
when people say you can't do it like the
doctor said you're probably never going
to surf again your arm's never gonna
work again like that's a big thing to
mentally overcome and you know people
are going to face adversity every day of
people who don't think they can do it
because people don't want them to do it
because then that means they're gonna
have to go do it right you know it's
like Comfort it puts you right in your
face like if this so when you surf the
78-footer that was 2000
2011. right now we're the same age I
think we're the same age so that that
makes you
uh 44 43 43 okay right so I love that
like that's that's that same year as
kind of when I was hitting my Peak as an
athlete and doing things I didn't think
was possible and that's a story that's
inspiring to other people but what
people don't get or realize or
appreciate is in the lead up to that
when you're doing the Reps and the work
to get to that point not a lot of
support like a lot of people are because
it's challenge like oh if you're doing
that that that means that maybe I should
be
deconstructing how I'm living and that's
scary for a lot of understandable
reasons right so you can't expect that
kind of support which means your nucleus
like the people that you surround
yourself with are super important and
this bond that you guys have is really
the key to you know everything it is
like the the nuclear power generator for
all of all of all of what is transpired
yeah yeah it's cool and and so I am
interested in like when when did the the
documentary like when did these guys
approach you I mean Chris Smith is not
going to make a surf documentary like
he's a super experience he's gonna he's
gonna tell really interesting nuances
Tiger King yeah pales like yeah it's
like this guy knows what he's doing he's
not like a surf documentarian he wants
to tell a story she doesn't like to take
credit for us going to Nazareth because
she answered the email and got us there
even though we wouldn't have went if she
didn't get on the email chain but
this documentary 100 would never have
happened without her and because she's a
projector she's very organized and she
wrote a little treatment that uh was
just super inspiring um
everything's possible and
um but it was really it was really going
to focus on Garrett cotty and CJ because
CJ broke his back Audi broke his back
yeah he's your brother yes and uh
Garrett's shoulder injury so it was
really about how the human spirit is
Limitless and we're all Limitless and
inspirational one-hour documentary yeah
I was gonna do it we were going to do it
ourselves you know like gorilla and um
my cousin is married to Joe Lewis the
producer
so I had called just for advice and he's
like oh this is really good and you know
it just worked out that he's like oh you
know I'll do it if you want so I knew in
that agreement that I was pretty much
giving away right
um creative Direction so he came on
board as the producer and the first
thing he did was get Chris Smith but
it's really funny when talking to Chris
if you ask Chris he'll be like yeah when
Joe said surfing he's like no way I had
no interest but but I'll talk to Garrett
forget for Joe yeah so we had this Zoom
call and uh
Chris says the only reason I did is
because Garrett's just so interesting
Joe did it because he said this is going
to win an Oscar
but the one and a half hour version yeah
so what was the decision to make it a
series as opposed to well I guess they
somehow got missed that we had
archival footage from hmm yeah a long
long time ago so we sent them just
literally a suitcase full of hard drives
full and when they when they saw how
much they had they they were like this
has to be a docu series yeah and now
almost crashed she was like my Oscars
but Joe's like don't worry get an Emmy
I'm like all right
I won the Emmy come on you know and then
uh and now season two you must have
already you've been shooting that yes
it's really hard yes it's hard to
believe but season two is better than
season one when is that gonna Premiere
uh probably January oh in January that's
coming up quick wow
so uh I mean congrats thank you
unbelievable
um Nicole when you
I'm sure you've gotten asked this before
but you know when when Chris is like
Carrie or uh Garrett is so interesting
like what is that quality in Garrett
that makes him different or capable of
Surfing these big waves like how do you
think about that like what is his secret
sauce and in that recipe of uniqueness
well it's interesting and I'm going to
take it back to humans you know it's
funny of that interesting word I use
that instead of saying it's not a
majority instead of saying it's so
interesting instead of saying something
negative a lot for you for people that
are just listening and not watching on
YouTube like he's making googly eyes
right right I mean you're very animated
and like you're your own character you
know like you're a cartoon character of
yourself in the best way and I'm not
saying that pejoratively like like in a
very you know endearing way so and
there's an earnestness to you you know
yeah charismatic there's a you but it's
not performative Charisma it's who he
really is exactly and that's why I take
it back to human design so generators
are meant to have these just super open
auras that just attract everything to
them because they're just so glowing and
fun and light and and genuine and what
happens is we become conditioned our
whole life to shut that down and as much
as I will say that Garrett's childhood
was completely disturbing
he didn't really get conditioned you
know his authentic like yeah yeah open
or beginner's mind
like yeah yeah there's an innocence to
him that
makes him just
you know he's he's a lover like he has
just a super loving heart at the end of
the day he's he's really a gentle gentle
person
[Music]
how does that translate into the
parenting stuff
that's a whole other podcast well it's
funny when he tries to parent I'm like
where are you like do you have
scientists well you have no right
exactly there's no example
so how do you know that this is working
have you read a book if you've read a
book and you have some uh research to
back it up there's something to be said
for that in this day and age like and
I'm sure there's a lot of that in your
in your kids experience but I'm very
lucky that they're very open to letting
the kids experience things yeah are you
capable of disciplining your kids
um I I mean definitely not uh physically
but um no actually I would probably
continue here and pull them can you set
a boundary here do you know how to set a
boundary like with your kids at times I
mean it depends on what you don't have
you never have yeah it's like so he goes
I don't know he always says what he has
the kids he's like I don't know it was
so easy I'm like yeah because you let
them do whatever they wanted to do and
then gave him whatever they wanted but
you as a as a professional athlete who's
done things nobody else has done there
is a certain
you have a capacity for discipline and
rigor in your life like you weren't
taught that that wasn't part of your
rearing right but you've learned that
for yourself and you've kind of
shouldered the responsibility of
creating that structure so that you
could accomplish these goals and I'm
sure I'm sure Nicole is helpful in that
regard but like it's un it's like an
unlikely story that you would become
somebody who could you know
uh apparent some children well parent
yourself like you've had you had to
parent yourself right so you had to
learn these things outside of the
household but I'm interested in like you
know the discipline the rigor the
accountability piece all of that you
know as a professional athlete like how
did you figure that out
I don't know I was I was always in the
health eating healthy whether I did it
all the time or not I already I was
aware from a from Young
uh yeah because we'd been vegetarians
and I you know we grew so many different
vegetables and fruit trees so they used
to call me Luther Burbank the world
renowned botanist you might have heard
um
but just because maybe from lack wanting
to achieve
figuring out how to actually achieve how
to succeed
and then just
I don't know how I actually uh
that one is a business plan for dummies
was definitely the Catalyst for the for
the ends for where I am now and after 35
right in the context of being an athlete
being a high performance athlete like
what is the training look like like how
do you prepare mentally emotionally
physically spiritually to drop in on a
wave of that gravitas I love training
and I love working out with a group of
people but I also like working out with
the just trip by myself with a trainer
and back in the day I would uh I had my
gym so I would do my weights and I would
ride my bike up pupuke hill and then I
would go the track at Sunset Beach and
run this quarter mile track where there
was benches every
on one leg of it and I would hold my
breath exercises there and that was
enough I credit my uh all my all the
experience I've had under the water were
enjoyable because I did my hold my
breath exercises today there's so much
more there's so many different
there's so much breastwork or even an
Iceman like a Wim Hof we got um just
it's all these free divers I mean
there's so many different tools now that
we can access through social media
through friends uh the breath work thing
was really interesting you brought in a
free diver to teach you guys uh you know
how to do static breath holds and Nicole
you got to like three and a half minutes
or something like that like doing that
but like that was so cool that you're
like let's we need to learn this if
we're going to be on these waves like
this is going to be a key thing to
understand
and then the the um
so many good trainers I was just in
Austin Texas training with all these
trainers I loved it I have a personal
trainer in Hawaii Sherry gunaway who's
a godsend she is just so Hands-On and
she actually does the body work which is
the best in the world that I've ever
experienced and I've had it all
treatments all over the world and she's
also like a psychic and I mean just yeah
and uh you know I trained with kyborg a
functional fitness gym and then Daniel
Bachman up at Sunset and in Portugal
there's a gym right in now is there two
or three gyms in Nazareth but that's
more I work through that on my own I
like working with the crew right I like
working with somebody or a few people
and talk to me about the yoga piece so
this Forest yoga is like have you ever
have you ever tried no no no
yoga is by far the best we've ever
experienced and we've well I love it
because it's really you know yoga now
what does it actually mean right and
today it's just you know I don't think
it is what it is today is not what it's
meant to be and that's why I really love
Forest yoga is because it kind of takes
it back to what it should be
um well I shouldn't even say should but
would it you know
what it is and
I love the ceremony part aspect of it
too which they didn't show much of that
in the series but you know every uh
every class starts out with a ceremony
like this deep
ceremony of gratitude and and the land
that our ancestors and and then it's
also about really how you were saying
the guy you had on your podcast last
week it's you know we hold our trauma in
our body
and it's using the postures to move that
trauma out of the body
and that's why I thought it would be
really great for Garrett you know not
only from his childhood traumas but also
his physical traumas and the scar tissue
and for all three of them yeah yeah it's
great yoga's yoga
I hate saying yoga but yeah you know
it's it's super important for your
mental and physical right yeah and your
your spiritual growth yeah yeah of
course you know so Forest yoga it's not
Forest like trees it's anaphor yeah what
was the name of the book that she um
yeah good job she's just she's Fierce so
powerful
[Music]
um she's a wizard yeah and beyond that
like so all right so you have the
weights and you have the breath holds
and you have the the breathing
techniques the cold baths yeah all that
kind of stuff like what else is part of
like I feel like
because big wave surfing is still pretty
new right like figuring out like how do
you prepare for something like this like
what is the best methodology to get you
right like you have to be physically
sound and strong of course and there's
techniques for accomplishing that but
like how do you mentally and emotionally
get your head in the right place to
tackle you know that kind of fear
inducing you know
for me
being physically prepared
strength and stamina breath then I'm
mentally I haven't been back to where I
was before I got hurt physically so I'm
still stuck challenged with Demento a
little bit
always wondering if I'm actually going
to enjoy it still as I always enjoyed it
didn't matter what was going on and now
I'm kind of and I attend you get back
yeah and uh the breath work is so
important uh
leading up you know for two weeks
minimum a month or two better and then
on your way out and while engaging
breath work like on your way up you
breathe up so you're hyper oxygenated
then you're sitting there waiting for a
while okay keep doing your breathing
you're getting ready to take that white
make sure you you you're highly you know
oxygenated Beyond and so when you
actually uh if you don't make the wave
the beat down will be enjoyable
um if you're not ready it'll be super
stressful and you could end up passing
out and then your body has to be able to
hold together the breath work I think is
the most important no spoiler alert
alerts but uh season two you know CJ has
the situation where he says like if it
wasn't for all my best breath work you'd
probably would have passed out yeah we
would have found him okay but yeah it's
I think because along with the breath
work depending which kind you practice
you know a lot of the breath work
practices these days also
you know touch on the spiritual and the
emotional part and you know you can go
to places through breath work that you
know you can reach some traumas and yeah
heal heal you can heal through breath
work you can have a medicine experience
yeah from the what is it the holy Travis
like who needs who needs medicine right
here breath my wife takes groups of
people through through those experiences
and then we all get together and share
and it's crazy what happens to people
yeah they have insane emotional
breakthroughs they go to different
places and are well it's just the breath
inhabiting the bodies of animals and
like all kinds it's like yes wilder than
any kind of psychedelicity it's very
very powerful and I think we're just at
the beginning of truly learning and
understanding the power of breath and
how to harness it for all manner of
things Beyond just respiration you know
it's it's super interesting
um
in the in the kind of context of your
story I mean it's super inspiring
um to see somebody Blossom and really
find their their their power uh like
later in life you know I feel like so
many people feel like the story of their
life is written at 25 this is who I am
this is my career this is where I live
these are my people and this is just
gonna be my thing right and you know
I've experienced a later in life kind of
transition or uh
um you know you know kind of different
kind of trajectory for my life and
um I see kinship and what in what you've
done in a different way you know doing
it later in life and so I think it would
be instructive to share a little bit
about
um you know what that has been like like
you could have stayed running that store
you could have stayed doing what you
were always doing and kind of succumbing
to the the pressures of just this is
what life is supposed to be like as an
adult and you know it takes a lot of
courage to break free of that and to
take a risk and try something different
especially when you're in your late 30s
or 40s and you you know kind of doing
what you're doing now into your 50s like
with no end in sight
I think it helps really it helps people
raise the ceiling on their perception of
what's possible for themselves
definitely
what was it what was it yeah what made
you at
35 beside this you know I know this
isn't what I want for my life I'm going
to go for it instead of because most
people would just I know I don't like
this but this is what I'm supposed to do
I just wanted to keep surfing yeah but I
think what it is Nicole it goes to
something you said earlier which is is
because
Garrett had this unique childhood
experience where he wasn't conditioned
in the way most of us
were he's been able to maintain a
connection with his childlike
sensibilities and what what gives and
gave him Joy right like you've talked
about like if you're struggling to
figure out what that is like go back to
when you were three years old right but
we have so much conditioning and
programming to prevent us from looking
in the rear view in that way and
connecting deeply emotionally with those
very pure kind of Primal impulses that
we had as as young people right but I
feel like you you what's unique about
you is like that connective tissue was
never ruptured
yeah I feel like in this world we're
conditioned to settle and to just do
what we're supposed to do
and somehow through my uh childhood and
and all my life I
I was not doing what you're supposed to
besides that one point in time when I
had the store and it just didn't feel
right and uh I mean just like
in my marriage I didn't want it you know
I settled at the end of the day I moved
on and I wouldn't be where I am today if
I didn't and uh yeah I really work on
not having any regrets whether you felt
it was a Pythagoras is it a bad decision
or not I work on not having any regrets
and and through that journey I I
released any regrets that I may have had
or any um
oh yeah I don't know
so for somebody who's maybe grappling
with their own discontentment
what is the recommendation or the advice
that you could give to that person to
help them kind of connect with something
deeper that might help them reckon with
it that's easy figure out what you love
doing figure out what you're that's hard
question about yeah that's hard to do
that okay yeah I would say that's what I
said go back to when you were three yeah
or the I I think the met the medicine
the beauty way the medicine wheel really
helped you the book
I mean the book is great because it it
it's simple this is no no this is the
medicine wheel
um I don't know it's amazing yeah but
it's hard to get great because it's
really simplified it so that people can
do the exercises in their living room if
they want they don't have to go into the
forest for four days with no food and
water I mean they could it's helpful but
the book is set it up to really you know
kind of look at the things that are
causing the pain and holding you back
and how to work through it right but
figure out what you think you like doing
or better to love doing it and then um
figure out how to make that your life
what the goal okay I love doing this how
do I make that a career and then you
make the road map you make the blueprint
and you follow it and you'll be doing it
and as I said don't stay rigidly
attached if it morphs to another
Direction go check that out um if if you
achieve it and you're really here and
you're like oh this isn't what I thought
it was going to be then go at it again
um yeah I think that idea of holding it
Loosely is important because if you are
too rigid then your your
short-circuiting your ability to be
available for the miracle yeah because
the miracle doesn't show up in a
pre-packaged way on time as predicted it
doesn't work that way right it's a
Meandering path and you kind of have to
have that North Star that's driving you
but also be kind of available and open
to the turns in the road along the way
because sometimes when those are those
are the messages that actually like lead
you towards the greater opportunity that
didn't even occur to you yeah great I
know the one path leads to a totally new
path you never thought even existed
she's getting Nancy don't worry we're
gonna wrap it up here I mean maybe that
um I do think I know you asked him about
fear I do think he oh yeah yeah there is
um
fear is you know something that we
choose something we manufacture in our
mind and it's when we're thinking about
the past or thinking about the future
and those two things do not exist so if
we fully embrace the moment and just
think about where we are in that moment
and do our best in that moment fear does
not exist it can't it can't live in the
present moment it doesn't
yeah that's powerful we had a great guy
uh Kent you know he taught us PCP just
be PCP and you know that's what he does
out with water and peace present and so
when you're fully present then you're
Connected To Source to Spirit and then
you're going to be protected
so present connected protected yeah PCP
really not what you're thinking a
different kind of yeah the other PCP
maybe not so present or connected
definitely not protected
um all right well what's on the uh what
are on all the sticky notes now like
what's on the the
screensaver on the on the iPhone like
what is the dream the goal you have a
picture of it here I don't know
fridge latest ones
it's been morphine lately we be
conscious parents
conscious parenting definitely at the
top
there's a few projects in the pipeline
you don't you you might remember some of
it that's important what what are the
goals right now that
love your wife there you go
you need a sticky note for that come on
I just don't like if you just love me
then I'll do everything else everything
because I'll be so watered and
blossoming that I'll just want to do
everything so yeah cool all right
um
are you uh so you split the you split
your time between Hawaii and uh Nazareth
now right like you you have a home there
and you live in Portugal half the year
yeah yeah we love Portugal we love
Hawaii we love La
um we have really good quality friends
here and we're really you know like
you're saying it's all about who you
surround yourself which and and uh the
funny one is do you want to hang out in
the in the ground and with the chickens
and eat worms or you want to soar with
the eagle so we've been really focusing
on um
quality friends and another one for lack
of a better expanders people that you
look up to or aspire to be like or or
really inspire you and they don't have
to be wealthy or anything just
inspirational people that have goodness
nothing about wealth yeah
it's good health health is wealth number
one is healthy above all there you go
buddy
um cool well I feel like we just touched
the surface on what I could talk to you
guys about but um I think we can wrap it
up for today that was amazing thank you
thank you I'm really inspired by the
journey that the two of you guys are on
and uh I can't wait to see season two
man it's exciting you guys are Emmy
Award winners now it's crazy you got
season two coming up in January and uh I
want to see all your goals manifest my
friend so consider me a resource if
there's anything I can do to to help
either of you thank you and you uh us as
well for you whenever you come to Hawaii
or Portugal let us know cool
um so obviously everybody should check
out 100 foot wave on HBO uh HBO Max
um where else should people go to learn
more about you guys your Mac Instagram
Macnamara underscore ass
and then we've got and then yours is
like Mama yeah Mama Unearthed right
that's good she's a philosopher she is
no stone unturned right
um
yeah on Earth your essence
listen to her all right right
um cool come back and and share with me
again sometime peace
there you go
thank you
[Music]